i know
while we're doing this uh uh interview
together it's madness in dc and i know
you used to work over there on dcb4 for
quite some time so
how are you processing this for yourself
when you see the madness in dc
with great displeasure uh
it's an under considerable
understatement you know i know that
building well i practically lived
in the capitol for a decade my wife
worked in the senate for more than 20
years
a little bit in the house you know
every nook and cranny of that building i
know and to see it desecrate
uh you know i'm you know it's
desecration of american democracy
to see that happen here is just off the
scale you know
you ever seen it like this before for
all the years you've been oh god no
i mean you can go back to the anti-war
protests
in the 60s i'm old enough to
live through that i was in college then
and
you know nobody did anything like that
you know there were hundreds of
thousands of people's
protesting uh in the 60s but
but nothing like this disrespect
for voting disrespect for
democracy disrespect for the american
way of life i think those
congressmen and senators are traitors to
america
who are violating their oaths of office
and uh it's awful
how do you think this is going to end up
because at this point you know uh
everyone's using the the name the title
president-elect
obviously if it goes the way it's going
president biden and kamala harris now
it's house now with senate
well i mean you know he's going to be
president and she'll be vice president
there's no question about it
uh as they should be they won the
election
you know the you know over 60 court
cases
you got to present evidence in court you
can't just make a speech and a claim
60 court cases lose every one of them
republican
leader of the state legislature in
pennsylvania
it's just trump's lying republican u.s
senator
trump's line in pennsylvania republican
secretary of state in georgia
republican governor of georgia their
lies
trump's lying republican governor
republican secretary of state in arizona
they're all lies the the person
the republican trump hired
to oversee election security says it's
the safest
most secure election in american history
so trump fires him
the you know attorney general of the
united states bill barr
authorizes every u.s eternity to look
for voter fraud
zero you know the in inbar was
was hated by democrats
i think for good reason i think he
played the role not of
representing the united states
but of representing uh trump but even he
says there's nothing wrong with the
election
so he goes everything that they're
saying is a lie
and uh you know i don't understand how
it got as far as it has in the capital i
just
turned the tv on a little while ago i
would have thought they would have
prevented
those the breach i
i guess sarah don't want to
use force to prevent them from going
forward for fear that it would
just incite much more yeah
uh but i think frankly i think the
point is they're just about at the point
where
i would hate to see that tear gas in the
us capital or anything like that that
that would just be beyond awful uh
but you know john i i'm a guy that came
here from iran i lived there 10 years
two years in germany at a refugee camp
and i've
come into the states and i'm watching
what's going on with politics in america
i'm noticing
the republicans are divided democrats
seem to be divided on the democratic
side you got the
aoc warren sanders camp and then you
have the biden
you know the rest of the camp and
they're a little bit divided socialism
no let's just say democrat we don't need
to go socialism
we can't stay with rad and then on the
republican side there's guys that are
mega and there's guys that are
republican and and
you know on both ends you almost see a
little bit of turmoil what do you think
needs to happen
for us to be a little bit more civil or
do you think things are just going to
escalate and get worse
well you keep thinking things are hit
bottom and then they keep getting worse
i say i don't believe you can equate the
divisions on the democratic side
with the republican side i we were
talking before we started the show
you know that i actually covered
politics
for 10 years my first book was on
politics
you know i'm pretty liberal but you know
newt gingrich and i had a
relationship he was the first
congressman i ever had
lunch with in the 80s you know he called
my first book one of three i'm not
trying to promote it i'll never see a
penny in royalties from it
never be but he did call my first book
one of the three best books ever
at non-washington you know back in the
80s
it was like two lawyers fighting in
a courtroom tooth and nail then they go
out and have dinner
there were close friendships close
friendships
uh between people in both parties we
were talking earlier you know tip
o'neill and ronald reagan got along real
well
uh danny rick rossian kowski the
chairman of ways and means committee and
bob michael the house republican leader
were very very close friends
uh you know and that
has dissipated there's there's
essentially none of that anymore
i the divisions on the on the democratic
side
are you know fairly
standard you know they don't hate each
other
inside the party they disagree over the
issues
uh they have always been like that
the republican side has gotten a lot
more extreme
you know there aren't any moderates or
very very few people
who would be considered moderate left in
the republican party
who were the classic fiscal conservative
uh they may claim to be but you know
they
give away the taxes and so forth and so
on uh
and now you have people on
you know who are so committed to trump
they believe anything that he says
uh you know outright lies that
have been disproved by every republican
and yet
people were just committed to trump
uh that's never happened
in uh recent you know i
i did drop out of grad school almost got
a phd in american history i'm gonna say
has it never happened ever in american
history i look back
and uh i'm trying to think go back
certainly not through the 20th century
uh
through in my head the 19th century
you know there were people committed to
andrew jackson but not like this
uh john adams you know when when
jefferson was elected president
adams wouldn't go to the inauguration he
left washington in advance
but there was no question over handing
over power
uh now there
it's never been anything like this and
we've never had
a leader in either party who incited
followers the way trump has done
uh you know it's
again we didn't you didn't have me on to
talk about this stuff but
you know it's happening in front of our
eyes and
i was watching fox which i don't usually
watch
but they were saying all the right
things that
this is a desecration of american
democracy this
is not who we are and yet it's happening
here and it needs to stop
what do you think the 74 75 million
folks who voted for him are most upset
about
well you know they've been lied to ever
since the election
so i
don't blame them for believing some of
the things that they've been told
you know tucker carlson for example just
to give you
a single anecdote you know had this
uh thing on about somebody dead who was
voting
a name whatever the name was john doe i
don't remember well
a reporter went out and tracked that
down and discovered
it was a 95 year old woman
who used her as some women do they
went by her husband's names mrs john doe
so
it wasn't john doe who voted she signed
in as mrs john doe
and it was misreported as her deceased
husband voting
well tucker cows in other words there
was no dead person voting
so tucker carlson makes a big deal out
of claiming a dead person but
he never corrected himself he never
issued a correction
explaining no it turns out it was
actually the widow
signing mrs john doe so if
that's what you see all the time i
i'm not surprised that some people
believe it so if you like this sort of
short clip from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye